a new toilet that can flush golf balls
and Natalie Portman's real name is
Natalie her schlagg Jackie Chan is come
some Chan and don't call me Carlos Rey
or I'll stick my boot up your ass Vsauce
Kevin here this is mind blow
things are not always what they seem
like loaf dog or in Super Mario 3 the
seemingly indestructible fire can
actually be extinguished if you use the
Tanooki suit this isn't a man with dry
skin these are actually pseudo realistic
3d paper portraits and sculptures um
Berto you have five seconds to figure
out what this jacket transforms into
okay an outhouse ah the jack pack is
also a sleeping bag
nighty-night lady some things are
exactly as they appear like the cave
theme from rygar being directly ripped
off and dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde
last week we saw bendable Oh le D
screams but now researchers have
unveiled the first bendable organic
microprocessor this will someday lead to
displays and sensors in anything from
clothing to foods so yes someday robots
will rule the world you close your foods
and your motorcycle but for now they'll
just play violin thankfully the
processor directing this car is the
human brain it works by using a sensor
cap that you program to read brainwaves
that alter when you think of a specific
direction sometimes our brains trick us
though like this MC Escher Waterfall
illusion brought to life follow the
water as it appears to flow up and fall
to spin the waterwheel continuously can
you figure out how this illusion works
deadmau5 figured out how to play the
Castlevania theme
and see how many levels of dew blocks
you can figure out to play the game find
the link below
finally here's an epic shadow sword
fight
it raises the question what's your
favorite fictional battle of all time
I'm going to leave you with a riddle the
first person to get the real right and
explain how they got their answer will
be featured at the top of the sauces
channel page as our genius of the week
after days with no incidents Elinor was
found dead on the apartment floor
surrounded by broken glass shards susan
was there with Elinor's blood on her
mouth but was not arrested why think you
know it leave your answer in the
comments below and as always thanks for
watching